a lot of you probably already know how I
feel about the shaving industry and the
corporate shaving industrial complex
call it what you will more blades
constantly replacing them etc etc my
beard is gone and that's because I was
recently sent the safety razor and blade
kit with shave cream from last razor and
I've talked quite a bit about how
shaving has gotten so expensive I mean
current cartridges are over marketed
they're generally over engineered that
inflates prices and they're sort of
based on the concept of free be
marketing also known as the business
model of razor and blades which is you
sell the actual razor really really
cheap but then you're really trying to
increase the sales of the complimentary
good in this case it's the blades
another example would be really really
cheap inkjet printers and you constantly
have to buy more cartridges and the
great thing about last razor is you can
actually just take out the single blade
from the safety razor set up you wash
off the shave cream and the hairs after
each shave it doesn't get put away wet
and start to rust it's hygienic every
time and I really like the shave cream
that came with the kit as well which was
just it's just smooth I mean I don't
like cutting myself last razor helps to
keep prices as low as possible they cut
out the big retailers in the middle they
will deliver to you right from their
building to your home and it's a
universal razor set up this whole
concept of oh this is a men's blade and
razor and this is a women's blade and
razor for their legs these razors and
blades can be used for any gender and
for any part of the body and of course
you get a better quality shave with a
safety razor it's also just way way
cheaper you get the free shaver with any
subscription purchase from last razor
you can use the code smooth at checkout
and it starts at just six dollars and
fifty cents a month for a limited time
so check it out last razor calm coupon
codes
move I did a hell of a job getting rid
of the the scruff which I know a lot of
people just don't like so i guess some
people will be happy to see it gone but
every time it leaves I guess I kind of
feel like something is lost but maybe
it'll come back check out last razor
last razor calm